رائده الفضاء السعوديان يعودان الى الارض
بسلام
علم صيني يفجر مفاجاه حول مصدر تسرب
كورونا
شجار عنيف بين لبنانيين وعراقيين في سان
باولو
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد رحله طريق استغرق الاثنت عشره ساعه
عادى الفضاء السعوديان ريان برناوي وعلى
القرني الى الارض بسلام عقب انهائهما مهمه
بحث في عمليه في محطه الفضاء الدوليه
امتدت عشره ايام ووصل برناوي والقرني الى
مطار هيوستن في الولايات المتحده فيما
اظهر الكشف الطبي الاول استقرار حالتهما
الصحيه كما اكد الاطباء انهما لم يواجهها
اي تحديات بشان التاقلم مع بيئه الارض ومن
المقرر ان يخدع طاقم الرحله لرعايه طبيه
مكثفه وبرامج التاهيليه متخصصه خلال
الفتره المقبله قبل عودتهما الى السعوديه
هذا الحديث مجددا عن مصدر فيروس كورونا
ليشعل مواقع التواصل حيث فجر عالم حكومي
صيني كبير سابق مفاجاه حول الامر قائلا
انه لا ينبغي استبعاد فرضيه تسرب كورونا
من مختبر البروفيسور الرئيس السابق للمركز
الصيني للسيطره على الامراض والوقايه منها
اوضح في تصريح لشبكه بي بي سي انه تم
اجراءه نوع من التحقيق الرسمي في مختبر
جوهان في اشاره محتمله الى ان الحكومه
الصينيه قد تكون اخذت نظريه التسرب في
المختبر على محمل الجد دون ان تكشف ذلك في
العلن وفقا لحديثه
تحضيرات خطيره اطلقها اكثر من 350 عالما
وخبيرا في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي حول
احتمال ان تؤدي هذه التكنولوجيا الى
انقراض البشريه ففي بيان المشترك بدعم من
الرؤساء التنفيذيين لشركات الذكاء
الاصطناعي الرائده قال الخبراء ان التخفيف
من هذا الخطر يجب ان يكون اولويه عالميه
الى جانب المخاطر المجتمعيه الاخرى مثل
الاوبئه والحرب النوويه واوضحوا ان تلك
الانظمه بما فيها تشات جي بي تي تنشر
معلومات خاطئه وتساهم بالجرائم
الالكترونيه فضلا عن التسبب في تعطيل
الوظائف على مستوى المجتمع
شجار عربي عنيف وخطير شهدته البرازيل
تحديدا في سان باولو حيث الشبكه العشرات
من اللبنانيين والعراقيين في شارع تجاري
وسط المدينه ما ادى الى اصابات بعضهم
بجروح ووفقا لمقاطع الفيديو فان المشتركين
استخدموا السكاكين والمسدسات الناريه
اثناء الشجار فيما افاد التقارير بان كل
ذلك حصل بسبب خلاف تجاري بين عائلتين
عربيتين وبحسب تقدير الشرطه فالعدد كان
يزيد عن 80 شخصا من جميع الاعمار ما دفع
السلطات الى اغلاق الشوارع المؤديه الى
المكان
وفي خبرنا الاخير اعلن علماء الفلك
التابعون لمعهد علوم الفضاء في ولايه
كولورادو الامريكيه وجود جزء ثان بل وجود
جزء ثاني للقمر يدور حول الارض لكنه مرتبط
بجاذبيه الشمس العلماء يعتقدون ان هذا
الجزء قد انفصل عن القمر منذ الاف السنين
وتم اكتشافه بواصله تلسكوبات متطوره
واجهزه رسم فضائيه فيما يعد هذا الاكتشاف
قفزه كبيره في تطوير تقنيات جديده
لاستكشاف الفضاء والتعامل مع الاجسام
الفضائيه القريبه من الارض وفقا لعلماء
الفلك